- [Girl] That's inappropriate.
- Are you trying to hit on me right now?
Is that what's going on?
(whooshes and squeaks)
(pulsing music)
(gags)
- [Guy] God.
- I hate vodka.
- I have never been to escape the room.
I don't even know what it is.
And honestly I think it's like a trivia.
- It's like an intense puzzle.
- Basically.
- Pretty much.
- I don't know, I guess
its like a roller coaster
for your mind.
- Oh.
- Oh my gosh.
- I think the game is based
on logic and hopefully
our logic is better than
some drunks peoples.
- It also depends on how drunk.
There's tipsy, there's turnt,
there's you know a little,
but then there's drunk.
- I won't like second guess myself.
- Yes.
- I feel like that's where
like alcohol will be a benefit.
(laughs)
- Drunk mind drunk thoughts.
- Sober, drunk, god be with us.
(pulsing music)
- Y'all lit?
- Yeah,
- Yeah.
- I'm lit as hell right now.
- I'm a bit, I'm like so
buzzed, like champagne gives me
to feelings like either
I just graduated college
or I need to nap for
like a good six hours.
- I'm kind of really need to nap.
- Was it a coincidence that our
room was named the hangover?
- I wonder who's gonna do better?
People on their way to a hangover?
- Exactly.
This is gonna be interesting.
- I'm nervous.
I believe in us.
Let's do it.
- I mean we got this.
- I literally have no idea what to expect.
(cheers)
- Come on follow me!
(dance music)
You guys must find the
mascot or your college career
is on the line.
You will be kicked out of school.
- Oh no.
- Let's do it.
- Yeah.
- Whoa!
Scary stuff guys, scary stuff.
- Wait but there's a,
there's gotta be a clue.
- I feel like i don't
have enough information.
- [Camera Man] So you
guys are still looking
for the first clue?
- [Black Shirt] Where,
you know what I think so,
I think so, yes we're
looking for the first clue.
- [Drunk Guy] Let's get the next clue.
- [Announcer] That's 20 minutes down.
- How has it been 20 minutes already.
- I feel like we've gotten so
much further than them though.
- We only have 25 minutes.
- I'm not even stressing.
- [Announcer] Alright
guys, it appears to me
that you need a little attention.
- [Blonde Braids] Oh no.
- [Sober Guy] Yes.
- You're doing this very
fast and I'm very impressed.
They can be slanted is that
what we're going off of?
- [Both] I think, oh!
- Shit.
- What is that?
I feel like I think of
all the other things
that alcohol helped but this part
is making it really difficult.
Boy number six, three.
- Oh guys its!
(cheers)
(playful music)
- If you had told me I
was gonna exercise today,
listen.
- [Sober Girl] I have no aim.
(fast forwards)
- There's gotta be another way.
(grunts)
Wait you guys, there's
gotta be a better way.
- Ah got one!
Jump and do it.
- Oh man I totally see Brandon jumping,
doesn't do anything for me.
- [Sober Guy] Shine the light from,
- Well maybe that's not
the only Statue of Liberty.
- I mean it could be just like France
but I don't think France is a gift.
I don't wanna do it.
(screams)
(laughs)
No, no, no thank you.
- Door is opening.
Alright you go in first.
- So is there any other gifts from France?
- [Sober Girl] Um,
that's not creepy at all.
- Did that just open?
- [Sober Girl] Did that just open?
Did we su, you know I'm
gonna let you go first.
- [Black Shirt] Wait.
- Sorry wanted to make sure
no one was behind the door.
- How did this open?
- [Drunk Girl] Pour some for the homies.
- [Stripe Shirt] That was creepy as hell.
- [Black Shirt] Ew.
- [Sober Girl] Oh wow.
(beeps)
- [Black Shirt] Listen this
is a literally scavenger hunt.
- [Sober Girl] I love this.
(laughs)
- Now put me in the right place to escape
- What is that?
What is it?
- The right place to escape.
- Oh we found the anchor!
(shouts)
- Wait how did we?
Get out.
I don't know.
- [Announcer] What would you call
the most expensive liquor at a bar?
- [Drunk Guy] What?
- Top shelf.
It's on the top shelf.
- [Drunk Guy] Well what
about the top shelf?
- [Striped Shirt] Wait.
We come 'cause there's,
(screams)
oh we got it.
(cheers)
- Great job.
You guys made it out.
- [Sober Girl] Top shelf.
- [Black Shirt] What
if we remove a letter?
(gasps)
- Congratulations.
(cheers)
- We did it.
(triumphant music)
(dejected music)
- It was so tough but I
wouldn't have been able to do it
without these two.
- Same
- It was just like a group
effort and even though
we didn't do it in like,
beat the record time,
we made it out.
- You guys, this was a great team.
I felt supported.
Felt like.
We like complimented each
other's thought process.
Like found clues before
they were relevant.
- Yeah me too.
- We also found clues
that like didn't match up.
- We had a good time.
- We used every clue there is.
- Every single one.
- You name it, we used it.
But we did not give up, we didn't give up.
- Yeah.
- It's alright guys, we still made it out
under 60 minutes, that's all that matters.
- [Striped Shirt] That's true.
- And we made it out.
- I do wish we beat the sober team.
'Cause that would have been.
- I feel like the planks
is what held us up.
- It did.
- In the beginning I was
like okay we got this,
it's a breeze, when it
started to get into.
- It was hard.
- I'm locking shimmy, I was like.
- It was tough connecting.
- Yes.
- And I think that our strength played out
in different parts.
- Yeah.
- I mean pretty good for the
amount that we were inhibited.
- [Camera Man] One, two, three.
- [All] Escape.
- Obama help us.
For so many more reasons than just one.
(playful music)
(whooshes and squeaks)